[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a california jury hands down a verdict
for ramesh sunny balwani former theranos
executive and ex-boyfriend of founder
elizabeth holmes plus the man who
attempted to assassinate president
ronald reagan speaks out for the first
time since his release i'm not sure they
could forgive me
and i probably wouldn't even blame them
if they don't forgive me if i could take
it back i surely would and what to
expect at the coming parkland school
shooting penalty trial i'm going to
expect from both sides that you'll
pre-trial your witnesses so that they
don't have diarrhea of the mouth or say
something that's inappropriate on the
stand but first former minneapolis
police officer derek shovin learns his
sentence for his federal case in the
death of george floyd law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman a nearly
21-year federal prison sentence is
handed down to derrick showing the
ex-minnesota police officer convicted in
the death of george floyd after pleading
guilty to federal charges late last year
a judge handed down the
252-month sentence on thursday with a
subtracted eight months for time served
cameras were not allowed inside the
federal courtroom but reporters there
say showman addressed george floyd's
family saying in part quote i wish them
all the best in their life and that
they'll have excellent guidance in the
rest of their life floyd's brother asked
the judge to give chauvin the maximum
consecutive sentence while his attorney
argued for 20 years saying shogun is not
a flight risk and has shown respect for
the court these federal civil rights
charges stem from the 2020 murder of
george floyd floyd an unarmed black man
repeatedly yelled i can't breathe as
chauvin knelt on his neck for nearly 10
minutes in 2021 shoving was convicted on
state charges of second degree
unintentional murder third degree murder
and second degree manslaughter in
floyd's death he was sentenced to 22 and
a half years in prison and five years of
supervised release u.s attorneys now say
chobin's federal sentence will run
concurrently with a state sentence
joining us today is legal analyst marie
pereira and co-host terry austin marie
where will shogun serve his time and is
there a preference or reason for one or
the other
most likely he will serve it in federal
prison and i think that was his strategy
and the first place for just pleading
guilty to those federal charges because
federal prison has a different type of
population the prisoners in federal
prison are less violent it's less
crowded the cell mates are less and even
the activities they force the
defendants to engage in in state prison
they don't do that to federal prisoners
they don't have assigned duties the only
downside is with federal prison they are
prone to transfer you to other states
without notice
and and state prisons they transfer
their pres their prisoners less often
yeah i bet you sharon's probably happy
about the federal as well because no one
in federal prison is someone that he may
have arrested in the past well terry
felonious floyd george floyd's brother
spoke at chauvin's sentencing asking for
the maximum time to run consecutively
but that won't happen so how will
shogun's sentence work
you know it is understandable that
george floyd's brother would want the
maximum he would want those state and
federal sentences to run consecutively
but it's not going to work that way
part of the plea deal was that it would
run concurrently and that he would also
serve that time as marie already
mentioned in federal prison because it's
a much better place for most people to
go but we already know that he began
serving some of his time in state court
so he'll get credit for that and we do
know minnesota law provides that you
absolutely get time off for good
behavior and it is two-thirds and so if
he is good he'll probably be out in
about 13 years yeah and then he'll
probably continue to serve that federal
time and then get out makes more sense
because you know
as maria said bounce back and forth
between one jail to another well in
other federal news convicted sex
trafficker elaine maxwell appeals her
conviction just days after a sentence is
handed down last month the british
socialite was sentenced to 20 years in
prison for her crimes in december of
last year she was convicted on five sex
crime charges stemming from her
relationship with the late financer
jeffrey epstein prosecutors say maxwell
lured young girls into epson's orbit and
groomed them into sex trafficking nine
days after her sentence was handed down
maxwell filed an appeal that could
stretch on for months previously
maxwell's defense team claimed
prosecutors did not prove their client's
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt saying
they waited too long to indict her
defense attorneys also called for a new
trial or thrown out conviction after
news broke that a juror failed to
disclose his childhood sexual abuse on
the jury questionnaire
and in colorado the defendant's car
becomes the focus of testimony as kevin
dean eastman has tried for the double
murder of his ex-girlfriend and her new
love interest eastman is charged with
two counts of first-degree murder
tampering with a deceased human body and
tampering with physical evidence he
allegedly killed his ex-girlfriend
heather frank and local greely colorado
musician stanley scott sessions on
separate days in february 2020 in what
prosecutors say appears to have been a
love triangle prosecutors have called
the throat-slitting murder of sessions
on ambush and that eastman fatally shot
frank to silence the only witness to
sessions killing frank and eastman both
had arrest warrants in connection to
sessions murder but for frank's body was
found investigators say eastman burned
session's body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body as well
when law enforcement arrested him at a
gas station on thursday a crime scene
investigator testified she was asked
about eastman's vehicle saying there was
damage to the front of it and that it
was found with the rear seats folded
down on cross-examination eastman's
defense attorney asked her what they
found inside his car
and as we just talked about you
carefully were looking for any type of
stains in mr eastman's vehicle yes just
like you did in mr sessions vehicle
correct because you were trying to
locate any potential blood
yes
um
and you did find
one stain in mr eastman's vehicle that
had an odor of
petroleum-based fuel yes you also
located seven stains and various other
portions of the vehicle
yes some of which were consistent with
potential blood some of which were
unusual stains that required further
testing okay uh you tested each one of
those seven stains in mr eastman's
vehicle i did
and all seven of those stains failed to
yield a color change consistent with a
presumptive positive result for the
presence of blood
yes in the screening tests they did
there is no evidence that anyone was
killed in mr eastman's vehicle
no
still ahead on law and crime daily 41
years after an assassination attempt on
president reagan john hinckley jr speaks
out for the first time but first a
verdict is handed down in the federal
trial of former theron ceo ramich sunny
bowani
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
ramesh suni bowani the former ceo of
theranos an ex-boyfriend of its founder
elizabeth holmes is found guilty in
federal court for his role in the
company's downfall a jury convicted
beliwani of 12 counts of fraud and
conspiracy for defrauding investors and
patients in theranose theranos was a
nine billion dollar
blood testing startup which touted
itself to have revolutionary
breakthrough technology in blood testing
despite flashy promises of using just a
few drops of blood to conduct a wider
range of health tests that technology
didn't exist
fairness raised more than 900 million
dollars from investors it came crashing
down when a wall street journal
investigation began in 2015 revealing
holes in technological capabilities the
conviction comes roughly six months
after theranose's founder elizabeth
holmes was found guilty of four of
eleven federal fraud and conspiracy
charges but whiny is set to be sentenced
in november he faces up to 20 years in
prison on each count a fine of 250
thousand dollars plus restitution
holmes's sentencing hearing is currently
scheduled for september
terry bowani was found guilty of all
charges unlike homes why do you think
that was brian you're right he was found
guilty on all 12 charges and that
included defrauding both patients and
investors and as you said we know that
holmes was only basically found guilty
for seven charges and that all related
to investors she wasn't found guilty for
any charges relating to patients i think
it's because balwani was the ceo no
question he had a more hands-on position
he actually oversaw the laboratory for
patient samples so he had more
day-to-day involvement and i think the
jury determined because of that he not
only defrauded investors but he also
defrauded some of those patients yeah
that makes sense with the additional
charges there now marie the federal
government got two convictions on
entrepreneurs that lied and used
hyperbole to sell a very important
medical device do you think this verdict
will affect how other entrepreneurs
market or sell their medical devices in
the
future absolutely i think this sends a
message the fact that they went after
him criminally
and not civilly
says you know what we're not tolerating
this it sends a message to ambitious and
deceptive entrepreneurs
who embellish who defraud not only take
people's wealth from them but this guy
was affecting people's health because he
claimed he had a machine with a drop of
blood that could diagnose 200 different
ailments and was misdiagnosing a
vulnerable public so not only did he
hurt the wealth of society if he hurt
society's health as well and i think it
sends a message that we're not
tolerating this
think first before you say let me fake
it until i make it yeah we'll see how
this plays out for hopefully not never
seeing future cases like this again well
adam montgomery the father of missing
new hampshire girl harmony montgomery is
facing new charges not connected to his
eight-year-old daughter's disappearance
harmony was last seen in 2019 when she
was living with her father and
stepmother in manchester new hampshire
harmony wasn't officially reported
missing until nearly two years later
officials say adam told child protective
services that the girl had been living
with her mother crystal sorry sorry says
that isn't true adam is being held on
charges of abusing harmony before she
went missing but so far no one has been
charged in connection to her
disappearance caleb montgomery adams
estranged wife was charged with fraud
for collecting food stamps in harmony's
name after the girl went missing the new
indictments related to adam allegedly
stealing a rifle and shotgun in 2019
include charges of theft and being a
felon in possession of a weapon adam is
set to go to trial for the theft and
other charges in november
coming up on law and crime daily we look
ahead to the penalty phase for the
parkland school shooter plus for the
first time since his release john
hinckley jr breaks into silence what he
says about gun violence in america
[Music]
welcome back for the first time since
his release from court supervision we're
hearing from john hinckley jr the man
who attempted to assassinate president
ronald reagan
back in 1981 a then 25 year old hinckley
shot and injured president reagan a
police officer and a secret service
agent at the time hinckley says he was
depressed and in isolation and became
obsessed with the movie taxi driver
starring jody foster hinckley later
claimed he shot the president to impress
fosser
he was convicted of 13 crimes but later
acquitted by reason of insanity hinckley
was diagnosed with five mental disorders
including borderline and narcissistic
personality disorder as well as major
depression he spent 41 years under
medical supervision majority of that in
a psychiatric hospital in washington d.c
after that he moved in with his mother
where his movements and medical status
were monitored by the court last month
he was officially freed from all court
oversight in an exclusive interview with
abc's nightline hinckley called for
stronger gun restrictions in the united
states
can you understand why some
would see you as a danger to society not
now no
why
because i'm not
if they want to think i'm the person
that i was 41 years ago yes i could see
that but that's not the person i am now
i certainly don't think the mentally ill
should have access to guns
i mean that's kind of obvious background
checks are good and
waiting periods are good i think there's
too many guns in america and coming from
you
that's quite a statement well
i hope it is
because that's the way i feel
so terry we talked about it a little bit
but hinckley was found not guilty by a
reason of insanity and sometimes people
think well they just get to walk free
but what was his life like being found
not guilty by that reason
well he certainly did not walk free as
you mentioned he was at st elizabeth's
hospital for 41 years he actually
tweeted that he was there for 41 years 2
months and 15 days so he was counting
those days he was under psychiatric care
he was actually on medication he
mentioned during that interview that he
went to both individual and group
therapy so he was trying to get better
and finally a judge determined that he
was better and he was put on
restrictions with his mother and now
he's completely free i think you know
there might be mixed feelings about that
but on the one hand it does show that
people can get better and that there is
some hope other people may want him to
stay in forever regardless of whether or
not he's better yeah i would agree with
that of different people having
different opinions there marie what can
this case conviction and hospitalization
teach us about mental health and gun
violence in america as we are in the
midst of shooting after shooting
mental health and gun violence appear to
go hand in hand coming from his own
mouth mr hinckley after 41 years in the
system getting intensive mental health
treatment being medicated i'm sure he is
telling us that there is too much easy
access to automatic weapons and that
there need to be a tighter control and
more background checks coming from
someone who came from that place and
what happened
to him what he did to the president it's
very very telling that he is advising us
to have better gun control laws yeah
it's one more voice to the choir of
asking for some kind of reform or some
kind of change i'd be curious to see how
much that weighs in a decision to have
change in this country for gun control
and gun violence well when we come back
the parkland school shooting a florida
judge sets guidelines for the nearly 200
2 000 witnesses involved in the coming
penalty phase trial
welcome back to law and crime daily
months after being convicted and
sentenced for the decade-old murder of
nba player lorenzen wright his killer
billy ray turner faces a second
sentencing on other related charges
wright was shot to death in july 2010
his body found days later in a wooded
area outside memphis tennessee for seven
years his case went cold then in 2017
turner and wright's ex-wife shira wright
were con arrested in connection to his
murder in march a jury found turner
guilty of first-degree murder in the
shooting death of the memphis grizzly
players after just a couple hours of
deliberations he was sentenced to life
in prison shearer was sentenced to 30
years in prison after pleading guilty to
her involvement in her ex-husband's
death turner was also found guilty of
attempted murder and conspiracy charges
which held a possible 15 to 25 years in
prison on friday a judge sentenced him
to two 25-year sentences he will serve a
total sentence of life plus 41 years for
his involvement in wright's murder
heading south to florida a broward
county judge rules all witnesses must be
pre-tried by attorneys before testifying
the coming penalty phase trial of the
parkland school shooter
back in 2018 the gunman opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida 17 people were killed
and 17 more injured last october the
gunman pled guilty to all charges after
a lengthy jury selection and multiple
delays the upcoming death penalty trial
is expected to begin on july 18th in a
series of pre-trial hearings this week
judge elizabeth shearer ruled the state
must conclude witness testimony by
august 19th nearly one month after
opening statements are expected to be
presented both sides also discuss the
sensitive nature of witness testimony
from thousands of witnesses the state's
witness list includes 1100 names while
the defense's list includes more than
300 on thursday judge schrier noted both
sides must pre-try witnesses before they
take the stand
i can't rule on every single issue that
may possibly come up i understand your
concern
but i think you put in the state on
notice
and and so that they have the
opportunity to
try their witness in the way that they
want to and make sure i i'm going to
expect from both sides that you all
pre-try your witnesses so that they
don't have diarrhea of the mouth or say
something that's inappropriate on the
stand and so if you want i'll issue a
this is a standing order
i expect at this level both sides to
pre-try all of their witnesses and to go
over
sensitive areas that that the witness
may or may not know they're allowed to
talk about
and i'm also
going to be paying very close attention
so that
if i see something that's coming i'll be
either interrupting or or
waiting for an objection in other words
if i see where if i can see where a
witness is going and it's in a place
that's not going to be good
um
i might say can we have a quick sidebar
or something for that effect
all right so when it comes to legal
terms diary of the mouth i know that one
but what does it mean maria to pre-try a
case and why do you think the judge
wants that to happen
i think basically she's saying if you're
calling these witnesses you need to prep
your witnesses and let them know what is
acceptable and what is not because i
don't want this case filled with
objections and sidebars they are your
witnesses control your witnesses
basically that's what he's um the judge
is trying to say i'll do my part but i
don't expect that the witnesses are
going to come in blindly and not know
the rules of the court and some rules of
evidentiary evidence by a
homosexual patient by a um a witness on
a stand yeah so again i'm not saying
it's not like an actual trial before the
trial it's more like an advanced form of
prep well terry the defense argues that
the use of too many photos or certain
evidence may inflame the jury and
prevent them from coming to an impartial
verdict so where does the line get drawn
for using hundreds dozens or just one
photo
you know what brian it's not an easy
line to draw and i think judge shira has
her work cut out for her there are over
450 photos and videos the prosecution
wants all of that in the defense has
argued that it wants less in and the
prosecution basically said look for just
one victim there are at least 11 photos
and we see that there are 34 people who
were shot 17 of whom died what judge
shearer said she was going to do is look
at each of these on a case-by-case basis
she's not going to make a blanket
determination and she has to figure out
what is inflammatory and what's
redundant i think she can do it yeah i
mean even if you do what ten each it's
three i mean it's a lot that's not my
strongest subject but thank you both for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you